ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen mannschaft
fällt um meine lieben freunde bevor
heute irgendetwas passiert haben wir
eine ganz ganz ganz ganz wichtige
aufgabe zu erledigen denn mir wird und
in die kommentare geschrieben dass hier
einfach ein williger feststeckt von
daher komme raus bilder
ich war unterwegs wir nehmen mit unserer
schere jetzt einfach mal im großen baum
hier ein eichenlaub ding weg und damit
können wir den baum jetzt wieder so ein
bisschen auffüllen ich glaube der wille
da hat sich da irgendwie so ein bisschen
drin versteckt weil der baum relativ
schnell gewachsen ist als ich damit
knochenmehl drauf gepackt habe und was
mir auch unten in die kommentare
geschrieben wurde war luca diese brücke
sieg gegen die nicht so ganz schön aus
es tut mir leid die wir auch mehr
provisorisch ich möchte ich eigentlich
gar keine brücke haben weil die eh schon
recht wenig platzes deswegen würde ich
hier einfach so einen sie rosenblatt
draufpackt und dann ist das hier quasi
unser übergang das hier sollte jetzt
natürlich nicht hier sollen da packen
wir mal kurz ein bisschen erde hin und
wo wir auch ein bisschen erde hin packte
ist hiervon an der ecke das habe ich
nämlich bei meinem letzten video gesehen
bei der folge dass ich hier vorn
außerdem grobe erde und nicht normale er
den getan habe deswegen wird das auch
nicht zu gras die schildkröteneier wurde
mir auch geschrieben die könnten nicht
schlüpfen wenn das gras wenn der gras
drüber ist deswegen macht das ist
einfach mal ab und hoffe dass das jetzt
mal ein bisschen voran geht und was ich
auch noch gelesen hatte war luca du
musst auf jeden fall dein schwert
verzaubern deswegen bin ich jetzt
einfach mal rüber jetzt zu meinem
enchantment table und werde das schwert
dort reinlegen plus ein bisschen
landesrat wie wir haben hier schärfe
zwei das hört sich auf jeden fall gut an
und damit sollten wir es auch hinkriegen
meine lieben freunde heute den überfall
zu sieben jetzt haben allerdings erst
mal was anderes zu tun und zwar wurde
mir geschrieben luca du kannst du
einfach diamanten zu deiner spitzhacken
an bord passen da kannst du die
reparieren
allerdings sind wartet ja immer noch
genug schon ein bisschen nervös ich
packe die restlichen sachen die ich im
inventar habe jetzt einfach mal hier
oben in das pas rhein da ist er
zumindest noch ein bisschen platz drin
ofenkartoffeln habe ich genug bogen
macht gar keinen sinn weil ich keine
pfeile aber vielleicht kritischer welche
eine rüstung ist auch noch relativ gut
vorhanden und deswegen würde ich sagen
dass wir jetzt mal gas geben
alles easy du alles gut läuft aber
weiter mit einer kaka am körper herum
was ist denn hier los ist sehr lieb also
tschüss ihr beiden auf jeden fall ich
werde mich jetzt in richtung schnee
billion bewegen und wir sind angekommen
im schnee die um meine lieben freunde
ich bin ganz ehrlich habe überhaupt
keine ahnung mehr wo das dorf war ihr
wisst ja jetzt mittlerweile koordinaten
gucken jetzt für mich keine option in
real life kann es ja gut man hat ein
handy in real life also das ist jetzt
auch nicht so ein guter vergleich
allerdings will ich das hier wirklich
alles ohne cheaten schaffen und jetzt
irgendwie zu gucken hey was waren das
für koordinaten wo war das dorf das ist
für mich halt einfach schieden ich weiß
dass es mittlerweile schwer dunkel wird
und ich habe leider die genau den
gleichen fehler gemacht den ich in der
letzten folge auch gemacht habe ich habe
mir nämlich kein mädchen mitgenommen das
heißt ich kann nicht schlafen gehen und
die nacht überspringen und
dementsprechend müssen wir den überfall
[Musik]
das dorf oder ich lass den eisbären hier
vorne einfach mal stehen ich habe keine
ahnung ob der mir gegenüber gut oder
schlecht gesinnt ist aber ich glaube
dass da hinten ist das dorf mit dem wir
es so ein bisschen uns verpackt haben
bzw nicht verpackt haben aber ich habe
zumindest den kommentaren gelesen dass
ich schuld an dem überfall war denn ich
bin bei den pillen oder wie die heißen
wer diesen räubern in ihre festung
eingebrochen und dementsprechend als ich
dann in ein dorf rhein gelaufen sind
haben die sich jetzt gerechter vorne
laufen sie auch noch rum das heißt wir
sehen auf jeden fall da wird weiter ja
der überfall findet statt meine lieben
freunde der spd ist heute tag schärfe
zwei lohnt sich auf jeden fall anstatt
zwei schlägen brauchen jetzt nur noch
anstatt vier brauchen jetzt noch zwei
schläge bis sie tot sind
der überfall balken geht auf jeden fall
langsam runter ich weiß nicht was ihr
noch abgeht ob diese anderen komischen
diese teile sind auch noch da das sind
gegen solche geister oder so wird mir
geschrieben die wurden heraufbeschworen
von dem makler und der magier ist
irgendwie der hier vorne der sj um die
kurve gelaufen glaube ich wir sind auf
jeden fall noch vor dir vor dein ernst
alter was geht ab
der hier vorne das ist glaube ich der
markt ja der ist auf jeden fall auch tun
hinauf echt gar nicht laufen ich weiß
schon was ist das was ist das was ich
dass man sie auch richard lugner lauf
lauf schnell schnell schnell oh mein
gott ich habe keine ahnung was sie
abgibt
ich habe keinen gott oh gott was geht
hier ab
das geld ja
[Musik]
auch ich ein
die herzen einer meinung
das geht ja was geht hier ab da sind
dann richtig viele oh mein gott da kommt
der typ wieder mit seinem komischen
badelt kopf meine leben sind nicht
komplett voll
und ich wollte auch nicht dass das hier
wieder so eine komplette action folge
wird ich wollte eigentlich nur meinen
mut holen und hier applaus aber wir
sehen oben nur noch ein verbleiben der
feuerwehr ich habe keine ahnung was
abgeben
hier kommen zombies ich habe keine
ahnung was das für komische viecher sind
die herumfliegen
oh mein gott ich muss mich erst mal kurz
ein bisschen was esse nicht vergessen
viel drin bei mir
das heißt sie können hier rein also ich
bin ja auch nicht sicher jeder zombie
kommt an der ist tot
also was geht ab fassen dass ihr für
teile das sind einfach fliegenden dinge
die hier rum
das ist ja geil die kommen von ihnen
hier oben glaube ich glaube die kompanie
mir
die hat er mich eine omega
ich bin dort hält was ist passiert
überfall sieg steht oben aber die leben
immer noch die leben immer noch die die
machen wir auch noch schaden kläger was
ist hier los der katze so lange nicht
vorbei der kampf soll eine nicht vorbei
was geht hier ab
was geht hier ab was geht ja die schaden
immer noch die schaden immer noch die
schaden nehmen auch diese anderen was
ist denn los aber da hinten das
feuerwerk die kriegen aber schaden
die kriegen schaden irgendwie durch
irgendwas was geht denn hier ab
sie verfolgen mich aber immer noch hält
da oben statt darüber fällt weg ich habe
auch irgendwas passiert ich habe um
rechts wegen nicht mit weil du sitzt da
fordere ich habe keine ahnung was sagt
die village aufreger zu mal rum ich muss
irgendwie schlafen
ich muss gegen die schlafen die zombies
attackieren mich es ist anscheinend noch
nicht ganz geschafft ich kann ich kann
schlafen werde ich vernünftig aufstehen
ich kann aufstehen
[Applaus]
das kann doch nicht
dass wir hier wieder nur action haben
mein leben ist voll von daher werde ich
jetzt einfach mal raus gehen die pfeile
bedanke ich mich dahin läuft betrieb
herum
ich habe keinen plan was das für
komische geister waren und ob die jetzt
mittlerweile tot sind oder noch immer
leben aber ihr volles erfahrung sind
denn die preise hier von dem so krass
runter ich hab doch noch gar nicht mit
dem gehandelt rotem der unsterblichkeit
ich habe auch irgendeinen ich lief man
von wegen held des dorfes also keinen
plan was hier abgeht und ob deswegen
weil ich die jetzt vor dem überfall
bewahrt habe ich jetzt irgendwie kratz
mit denen auf einer wave das ist sicher
so klar dass also ein krieg elsner ich
klicke jetzt mal mit dem verordneten
fleisch auf balou drauf das kann nämlich
essen das wollen wir auch unten in die
kommentare geschrieben und dadurch kann
ich mein fahrrad das fleisch also ein
bisschen verbrauchen davon habe ich am
ersten tag noch zuhause rumliegen balu
kommt ihr auf jeden fall ganz schnell
mit ich habe keine ahnung was jetzt noch
so groß der plan ist für heute ich
dachte ehrlich gesagt dass es mit dem
überfall ein viel größeres thema wird
aber louis gilt und dann würde ich mich
jetzt mit balu allerdings auch auf den
weg machen ich kann doch mal hier vorne
ein bisschen gucken hier sind nur ein
paar schweinchen da könnten wir
eigentlich welche mitnehmen allerdings
muss sich erstmal beruhigen die mit
kriegen hier die laterne nämlich immer
noch mit hier die ausrüstung aufwerten
das nämlich auch mal mit ich habe keine
ahnung ob ich damit irgendwas machen
kann oder was man überhaupt damit machen
kann
allerdings ist das heutige ziel ja
erstmal mit balu zurückzukommen auf
unsere insel und dementsprechend alles
was ein bisschen ordentliche fugen zu
bringen jetzt auch ein schäfchen also
wir können nicht irgendwann wirklich
tiere mitnehmen weil nun läuft hinter
mir her glaube ich genauer teleportiert
sich und wir laufen wieder in richtung
wasser wir verlassen jetzt das erste mal
dass neben hier vorne es war zwar
wirklich sehr krass sich das alles
einmal anzuschauen und auch generell die
beiden neuen dörfer dazu entdecken und
dieses komische festungs ding was wir da
auch noch gesehen haben
allerdings freue ich mich auch wieder so
ein bisschen auch zu hause und jetzt
erstmal auf eine bau folge in der
nächsten episode oh mein gott das ist ja
richtig ihn hier das ist ja das stelle
ich an eine skizze unter beweis
es war schon cool in der
schneelandschaft also ich glaube da
werden wir auf jeden fall mal wieder hin
geben hier vorne sind wir jetzt auch
schon wieder bei der inselgruppe
angekommen wo ich ja immer mein
holzabbau und dahin am horizont sehen
wir auch schon meine insel
also es ist wirklich nicht so weit weg
dieses ganze schnee biom ich fahre hier
keine ahnung mit dem brötchen vielleicht
zwei drei minuten oder so allerdings
bevor wir jetzt hier vorne gleich halten
und auch mal kurz glaube ich unsere
fichte abfällen möchte ich auch noch
ganz kurz um etwas bitten und zwar
trommelwirbel meine lieben freunde
haltet euch fest in der folge die
übermorgen online geht werde ich die
insel reparatur machen und dafür brauche
ich eure fragen unten in den kommentaren
von daher meine lieben freunde wenn ihr
irgendwelche fragen an mich halt
irgendwas nicht nur unbedingt vielleicht
auch projektbezogen sondern generell
bekommen
der ist echt ziemlich langsame wasser
wenn irgendwelche fragen an mich habt
anregungen irgendwas über das sich reden
soll dann schreibt auf jeden fall gern
mal und in die kommentare
denn ich wollte in der nächsten folge
daran so ein bisschen mal darauf
eingehen denn es wird halt wirklich
ziemlich langweilig wenn ich einfach nur
rumlaufen und meine insel so ein
bisschen repariere das wort ich nur ganz
kurz sagen was sie auch mal sagen wollte
war ganz ganz viele von euch feiern ihr
das projekt hier allerdings sehe ich das
ganz ganz viele kein ich mir denn jetzt
weh getan ich habe letztens in den
statistiken von meinem youtube-kanal
gesehen das ganz ganz viele sich meine
videos anschauen allerdings nicht
abonnent sind deswegen klickt einfach
mal auf abonnieren es ist kostenlos und
wenn ihr eure meinung ändern wollt dann
könnt ihr das auch immer noch tun ich
hole mal eben kurz das zuckerrohr noch
so ein bisschen hier und hier vorne sind
auch noch zwei neue gewachsenes können
uns direkt neue bücher machen hier bei
lydia schüttelt sich so ein bisschen
raus also balu jetzt komm mit wir gehen
jetzt eben schnell schlafen und am
nächsten tag haben wir dann
endlich gar nicht so raus da ich gepennt
wir haben ich bin einfach dorf hält was
los hier vorne sind noch ein paar
ofenkartoffeln drin und hier auch ich
glaube allerdings dass wir unten auch
noch kartoffeln haben die wir da oben
mal beraten können genau hier zack zack
sagt die nehme ich auch mal mit und
damit können wir wahrscheinlich noch mal
wieder ein bisschen füttern das hat
jetzt länger nicht zu essen bekommen
jetzt spielt auch einfach die ganze zeit
wieder in meiner wohnung hier oben also
hier kommen können die kartoffel und
jetzt lassen wir das schweinchen ja auch
mal rau ist also das ist ja lange noch
jetzt herauslesen kann bei ludo kann es
auf jeden fall hier mit rein kommen die
kartoffeln packe ich hier vorne mal rein
und die anderen auch hier vorne da
können jetzt auch ein bisschen kohle
reinpacken haben ja auch noch ganz viel
wir müssen auch in der nächsten folge
mal wieder etwas bauen da wurde nämlich
auch was in die kommentare geschrieben
was ich euch jetzt aber noch nicht
einwenden das ist jetzt noch ein kleines
geheimnis allerdings wird es wirklich
sehr sehr sehr sehr cool ich werde jetzt
allerdings mit balu erst mal ganz kurz
da hinten noch mal aufs wasser gehen
denn ich muss dort jetzt eine zweite
fichte hinsetzen ich habe ich habe ja
noch einen fichten setzlingen am start
deswegen werde ich hier sagen wir mal so
einen kleinen weg rüberkommen ich frage
der fina hat ist das thema ist es für
banken ist es nicht flipper wo ist denn
flipper das totem der unsterblichkeit
packe ich mal einfach hier meine
wertvollen kiste dass papa ich hab halt
keine ahnung was ich mit diesem pana
machen kann kann ich die nehmen
ok
[Musik]
jetzt dass ich ganz einfach so hin
hängen sehr schön aus ich habe keine
ahnung aber wo wir hier gerade sind
können wir auch ganz kurz meine steige
sekunde für die verstorbene katze und
verstorbene kuh einlegen und dann bauen
wir unsere strecke hier mal ein bisschen
weiter das ist ja das perspektivische
ziel dass wir irgendwann mit dieser
strecke auf der gestern auf die andere
insel kommen und dementsprechend dann
dort einfach
immerhin fahren können mit meinen karat
ich habe mir das so vorgestellt dass ich
dann noch so ein bisschen fragen
beantworten kann während ich immer in
dem katrin sitze ja schon ein bisschen
langweilig aber ich bleibe euch mal kurz
zum teil lag sein
[Musik]
wir haben hier bei unserer bahnstrecke
auf jeden fall noch einiges zu tun in
den nächsten folgen ich würde auch sagen
dass wir irgendwann nochmal unten in die
höhle gehen und die restlichen schienen
holen die dann noch um lagen allerdings
wird es auf jeden fall es wird viele
haben ja auch geschrieben dass sie hier
ich das mit redstone blöcken machen soll
weil diese fackel irgendwie doof
aussehen
ich finde eigentlich ganz schön weil
gerade jetzt hier wo es auch dunkel wird
sieht man das wenn das hier dann einmal
durchgezogen wird mit den rettern
fackeln die zwar ein bisschen aus wie
seine flugzeuge landebahn oder wie so
eine richtige strecke und das finde ich
eigentlich deutlich besser als wenn das
dann so komisch unbeleuchtet wäre ich
würde allerdings sagen ich geh jetzt mal
schlafen in beziehungsweise blödmann
fertig doch direkt mal ein bisschen
traden mit ihm ich würde an der stelle
die heutige episode gemeinschaft mit
lukas allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben freunde ich setze doch mal eben
schnell unser eichenholz bot hier vorne
hin und unser mine carpet im silo hier
vorne hin
es war heute eine sehr interessante
folge glaube ich ich hatte noch nie für
eine folge so wenig plan wie für heute
allerdings war es wirklich mein einziges
ziel einen kleinen kater namens blue zu
holen und auch einfach nochmal den
überfall da hinten in angriff zu nehmen
und die villagers ein bisschen zu
befreien ich habe immer noch das hält
des dorfes euro jetzt geht die zeit auf
jeden fall runter also ich glaube es
steht nicht die ganze zeit hier so dumm
rum ihr könnt mir auf jeden fall gerne
und in die kommentare schreiben was sich
erstens mit diesem held des dorfes
anstellen kann zweitens was ich mit dem
toten der unsterblichkeit machen soll
und drittens könnte mir auch fragen in
die kommentare schreiben für die nächste
folge microsoft mit luca übermorgen wo
wir die insel reparatur folge machen
werden wenn ihr diese folge dich
verpassen wollt dann lasst den daumen
hoch und ein video der abonniert main
kanal
falls doch keiner der luxus seid und wir
sehen uns dann wieder jury
[Musik]